hello and uh thanks for coming to my
talk on computing efficiently on encoded
data i'm really excited to talk about
this uh this is some joint work i did
with mary ruders who's right there
okay uh so
let's start so i'll first explain the
problem setting in distributed storage
and then i'll describe our result there
uh which pertains to read solomon codes
our main result um and then i'll step
back and just explain why we worked on
this why we defined this new problem
what are some
similar ideas in the literature and what
was our motivation for for working on
this
and then i will
explain what a linear recovery scheme is
and how we used those to get our results
and then i'll conclude with some future
work directions
so let's say that you have b bits
here and you want to store them on some
computer nodes and
one way you might do that is to just
split up
your b bits into chunks so you have a
chunk of the bits on each node and when
you want to get your bits back you can
just download
b bits and that's called the bandwidth
of recovering all your bits
and uh this naive approach is very
simple
and
but but we really care about minimizing
bandwidth in this talk
and uh so if you really just wanted to
compute some function f of your bits and
you didn't care about recovering all
your bits maybe
you know sometimes you'd be able to get
by with fewer than b bits downloaded and
that's what we're interested in doing
and um you know so uh but but uh for the
functions that we consider in this talk
if you use this naive setup you're just
you can't do better than b bits okay um
so there's a very serious problem though
with this setup and which is why it's
not uh not going to be used so
if you lose one of your nodes out of
your many nodes
if one goes down and your data is lost
then you can't recover
that chunk you can't uh you can't you
can't get it back uh because there's no
error correction
uh and you can no longer compute
functions like f if they depend on that
chunk of the bits
so uh we know how to solve this problem
using an error correcting code
and so if you use one of these codes you
encode your message
the bits
and they take up a bit more space
and so you put them on more nodes
perhaps but
you can still just download b bits
and you can recover your your input bits
as long as you've chosen a reasonable
code um and certainly the code's in this
talk
so
once you download the b bits you can
compute this function f
and that's
like kind of the naive approach again
to computing this function f
and and then
now that you have this code
if you lose one of your nodes
it's okay as long as not too many nodes
are lost you can do error correction and
you can recover all of your data
which is really good
so
we looked at this problem
when you're using a read solomon code
so we said okay you're going to view
your
message bits as comprising k symbols
in some finite field of order big
q and so so if it's big q
symbols in the field then each symbol
can be encoded as log 2 of q bits
so in total that's k log 2 of q bits
it doesn't have to be 2 bits per per
symbol uh that's just what i've shown
here but uh in general you'll have like
some finite field and you'll have k
symbols of that field and b is equal to
k log two of q
and you just uh encode those in this
code called resolument code
okay great
so this code is is nice for a lot of
different reasons and it's used in
some systems like it's it's built into
seth and hdfs which are distributed file
storage systems uh and
just like you know it's a reasonable
code you can download b bits and you can
recover your message and you can compute
a function on your bits that way
but we were interested in the case where
the function you want to compute happens
to be a linear function over this field
fq
and
this is just a natural class of
functions you might want to compute so
it looks like big f of your message
symbols f1 through fk
is equal to the sum over i of
lambda i times fi
where the lambda i are arbitrary
elements of this field fq
so in other words you want to take the
dot product
of this lambda vector with your message
vector f1 through fk
and
what we showed is that for this class of
linear functions
if you pick any pick any one of these
functions
you can get by downloading just a little
o of b bits
to compute that function
so uh little o b bits across all the
nodes uh in total uh and
and that's that's gonna allow you to
compute f
and this is uh really surprising you it
works for any
coefficients lambda i and and um
of course the bits that you download may
depend on the lambda i but
for all lambda i you can uh you can
make the correct queries and then you
can you can recover this uh this linear
function
okay so this was extremely surprising to
me
because i
when i first started working on this
project i just kind of uh
naively assumed that an error correcting
code was kind of like a big bulky suit
of armor and so it offers protection
but it is going to slow you down and you
know meaning it's going to be more
difficult to compute on your data
because now it's encoded and you have to
think about that and worry about
decoding it or something
but it turns out
like our result shows that at least for
these uh for the purpose of linear
computations the reed solomon codes are
more like the iron man armor and that's
because they don't just protect your
data but they give you this new
capability of computing this you know
any arbitrary linear function
with b divided by log b that's the
little of b from before uh bits
downloaded and
so this is only possible because when
you encode in the read solomon code
you're just you're doing some
non-trivial computation on all of your
message symbols to produce the code word
symbols and then you're storing those
and so you have this kind of like
library of these lin these existing uh
pre pre-computations that you've done
and so by making intelligent queries to
the nodes
you can do uh better than the naive
approach which would require
b bits to compute
the linear function
and
okay why do we work on this
so
this this idea that you have encoded
data and you want to compute on it and
you don't want it to cost a lot of
bandwidth has shown up before in several
different places so the the first place
is regenerating codes and regenerating
codes
are so in that context imagine like for
example a single node failed like i
showed before and all you want to do is
replace it so you need to
recover by making queries to all the
other nodes you need to recover
that codes sorry that node's code word
symbol right and that's just a special
case
of computing a linear function right
because for a linear code the codeword
symbols are themselves linear functions
of the message symbols
so our work in that sense it directly
generalizes regenerating codes
and it's also related or similar to
ideas in coded computation and gradient
coding
and homomorphic secret sharing
and so there's a lot of existing work in
all of these directions
and
you know variants of this problem have
shown up uh and what we do in this work
is we define this new problem of just
computing unencoded data
kind of like regenerating codes but but
generalizing that to arbitrary linear
functions
and uh you know that we make the first
we take the first step uh
in in computing these arbitrary linear
functions
so what our specific result is i'm just
going to state it here for some fixed
rate r and then let's based on the rate
we'll fix a sufficiently large prime
power q
and
we'll consider the class of read solomon
codes of dimension k which is r times q
to the t
and full length meaning we use all the
evaluation points in our in our field f
q to the t
so n is q to the t
and uh okay really important now we have
little q
so
big q from before is is just going to be
little q to the t and i'm going to keep
keep little q red uh to remind you that
this is there are two different fields
now
um so for any set of coefficients lambda
1 through lambda k
then we can compute
uh lambda transpose f where f is your
message vector
by making queries to these nodes
and the total bandwidth cost is just
proportional to
in bits
and if you think of q as a constant then
this is uh like b over log b bits if the
total message size was b bits
so uh this is our result and
it of course is a bit more general than
this it can handle these failed nodes
so they don't have to participate uh
they could just you know sit uh sit out
for one of the rounds and they don't
have to help us
and we can also
handle equivalently fewer than q to the
t evaluation points
because if you know some nodes have
failed well maybe instead they just
never existed in the first place and
it's the same thing
as far as the scheme is concerned
i'll just note though that that our
bandwidth cost is the lowest when you
use all of the evaluation points in the
field
and you are able to contact all of those
nodes
um
and you can vary in our full theorem you
can vary this base field size q
you can
you can vary the rate you can vary the
fraction of the nodes that participate
of course there's a maximum limit of one
minus r times in
failures before you'd actually start
losing data
and
one
perhaps the limitation is that you do
need to work over an extension field
like f q to the t
and
so we we do mention that a hack of sorts
for working over
prime fields so if you really had
messages in a prime field you want to
you know you want to compute linear
functions of them if you had several of
these messages then you could use our
scheme to perform batched linear
computations on them in parallel with
low bandwidth
but the way that you do this is you view
those stacks of messages as like
representing messages in this extension
field f q to the t
so there's still this notion of this
extension field showing up
uh so just to review we have f1 through
fk
in our
base in our field f big q to the k
and now we encode it so how do we encode
that in a resolument code well you just
consider your message symbols f1 through
fk as the coefficients of some
polynomial of degree at most k minus 1
and then
you fix an evaluation point so just some
alpha i for each of the nodes
and
each of those points comes from the
field f fq
and then you evaluate that polynomial at
the evaluation point corresponding to
each node and give that you know
evaluation to that node to store
and so this is a read solomon code and
now we let's say later decide on some
function sum over i of of lambda i times
f i
and we you know we really need to
compute this function so
we just have to broadcast that uh
function to all the nodes
and then we can download a little of b
bits total and use those bits to recover
that function
great so the schematic for how this will
work is we're going to just focus on
linear codes
over some extension field and you can
imagine like little q is fixed and t is
growing and that's how we grow the field
size in the code
and then we'll treat the code symbols
these evaluations f of alpha j
as actually being vectors uh in the
vector space f little q
to the t so the t-dimensional vector
space over the finite field of order
little q
and then we'll make f little q linear
queries to the vectors in other words
we'll just multiply those vectors by
some suitable matrices and then you know
the resulting vectors will be what gets
sent back to us
and then we'll reconstruct you know from
those queries we'll reconstruct with the
linear combination
of those queries the
desired linear function
okay so how do we view a field element
like this alpha in
f little q to the t
as a vector of t dimensions over f
little q
well
uh this may or may not be surprising but
you can do this there is an encoding
to go back and forth and this works
really well um
f little q to the t of the extension
field it also has a vector space
structure over f little q so
as soon as you fix a basis then then you
can do this mapping and uh addition
works fine so you know alpha plus beta
in the big field is just uh rep you know
if you do the the encoding to some u's
and and v's and then you just add up
those vectors you get the appropriate
vector for the appropriate field element
that represents alpha plus beta right uh
so addition works fine and we can also
make multiplication work really nice and
the way we do that is we can encode so
let's say that we want to compute like
lambda times beta where lambda and beta
are in the big field f little q to the t
and okay so we can do that by
finding some big capital lambda that's a
t by t matrix with entries in f little q
such that when we when we multiply that
big matrix by the vector that encodes
beta which here's v
then what would we get out will be the
vector that represents lambda times beta
okay
so we can make this uh we can make this
nice mapping and we can map field
elements to vectors
to add them and it all works fine we can
make them into matrices uh with
everything has entries over the little
field and i'll use this this depiction
to
show what's going on in our construction
so uh for our construction
the just to review the user comes along
and has some linear function they want
to compute
and the
let's say this is some node i and they
have the code word symbol f of alpha i
well
they're just going to choose to view
that uh you know assuming that that the
symbol is in some big extension field f
little q to the t
they can view that as this t dimensional
vector with entries and f q
here that's u
and then they're going to take that
vector u and multiply it by some matrix
a
and they get some new vector which they
send back to the user and let's say
that's an f q to the s
so s is the number of the base field
symbols the um
the order q field symbols that we get
back
from this node
so they get back a u
and
so a has to be s by t in order for the
uh vector that gets sent back to b s
symbols
and in our construction we find a way to
keep
s proportional to a constant right as
long as you don't change the rate or the
base field size
or the of course
number of
nodes sorry the number of evaluation
points in your code
as a fraction of the field size f q to
the t
okay so
how do we what do we do with this right
the user got back this a times u well
they're just going to sum up over all
the nodes j
uh r j times a j u j right so they
receive a j u j is some s dimensional
vector and they multiply it by some tall
t by s
matrix r
i haven't told you yet how you get the r
matrix or the a matrix but if you if you
have the appropriate matrix then
matrices then this would define some
linear recovery scheme for this this
code so this is what a linear recovery
scheme is it's linear over this base
field f little q
and this is what it looks like and this
is exactly what we will do
so when we when we zoom out across all
the nodes we get back a1 times u1 from
the first node and so on we get all
these s dimensional vectors
and so that's just if q is constant it's
proportional to s bits across all the
nodes
and so in total if we can keep
that s small then like i mentioned we
get little of b bits we get o of n bits
overall
and then
how
do we reconstruct or how do we get the
appropriate rj and aj uh that's the
remaining thing to be explained so
uh
let's let's just uh write down f the
message symbols as f1 through fk
and then of course the code word
is this these evaluations f of alpha one
through f of alpha n
we'll call that c
and
remember lambda is the vector of
coefficients and we want to compute
lambda transpose f
so the first observation is that you can
equivalently write this as gamma
transpose c or c is the code word
for some appropriately chosen gamma uh
in dimensional vector of some other
coefficients
and this is true because this is a
linear code
and so encoding and decoding are linear
operations
and so you can just do those operations
in between
lambda and f and then you know you get
instead gamma and c
so uh the gamma is not necessarily
unique
but uh there's there's some gamma and so
pick any gamma and we'll work with it
so what we're going to do next now that
we've transformed it from thinking about
lambda transpose f into gamma transpose
c
as we'll just expand the gamma
symbols into matrices and expand the c
codeword symbols into these two
dimensional vectors
and that way we can write it in this big
block notation
and so we have gamma 1 through gamma n
comprising this big
vector
uh gamma but now capital gamma is like
these matrices that are t by t
and great so recalling that c which is
now represented as this u1 through unin
stacked vector
that's a code word
right of this linear code
so there's a uh there's an idea which is
to add
a row corresponding to a dual code word
that that when we multiply that row
vector by u will just give us 0 because
that row vector came from c perp the
dual code
and
this this holds
even though we've expanded it into these
big t-dimensional
chunks for each symbol
it still holds that that the inner
product will be zero so
all we've done when we add this row to
let's say the last row of the big gamma
block matrix is we've just added 0 to
the right side
so it's still true
and so we do it again to a different row
of the gamma matrix
and we just do it with some you know v w
and z
for all the rows and now when we look at
the jth block gamma j uh sub block plus
the wj zj vj
uh symbols that then that resulting
matrix
we want it to be low rank so we want it
to have rank s
and once it has rank s then we can
factorize that jth block into r j times
a j
where r j is t by s aj is s by t
and once you do that then now you see
this equation from before that
reconstructs lambda transpose f
as equal to gamma transpose c which is
equal to the sum over j of rj aj which
is just that jth block
times uj
and this is exactly where we get the
linear recovery schemes
so i i haven't shown you how how to get
these dual code words those colorful
rows right
and
our construction only
is for read solomon code
and uh
the result that we get is that s is
indeed a constant for fixed rate etc and
the total bandwidth is then order in
bits
which is uh b over log b
and
if you use the naive approach which
would be to download uh all of your data
recover all your data and then compute
the function that would be o of b bits
for for b bits of your data
so this is a this is an improvement and
it turns out that at least uh the
dependence is optimal for
the dependence on b if you have a
constant rate code
and because we have a lower bound for
any mds code of b over log b as well
and but this lower bound assumes a
linear repair scheme that works you know
in the way that i've described
so uh there is a gap for the dependence
on rate so if you vary rate if you vary
also the number of failed or
non-participating nodes
um
which which okay so here here's that gap
so
uh on the left here we have this lower
bound of this proportional to n or b
over log b bits
and uh and then in the middle we have
our the bandwidth for our scheme
and you can see it's also proportional
to n
and then the trivial scheme would
actually be in login bits order in login
bits right
so uh
there is this gap uh for future work to
just find the correct dependence on the
rate
and q
and also so i haven't mentioned before
what gamma is
little gamma is just the fraction of
failed nodes here uh so
it's you know a direction for future
work to find the correct dependence on
those quantities
another natural direction for future
work is to generalize to other code
parameter regimes for example when
t is very large or
right if if you want to use fewer
evaluation points and not use this
entire extension field
and
and uh also it would be cool to
generalize beyond linear functions maybe
to low degree polynomials we have an
idea in our paper for uh how to compute
some
some nonlinear functions
using our methods
but that's just some of the nonlinear
functions and there are a lot more um
so that's another direction
and
another
would be
so so khan and tama of this pioneering
recent work exploring
so they create regenerating codes over
prime fields
uh instead of extension fields and they
do that with a non-linear repair scheme
and it would be really cool if you can
use a nonlinear repair scheme for
computing on encoded data instead of
just repairing a codeword symbol and
maybe even a non-linear scheme to
compute a non-linear function
and okay the advantage of this is it
might help you work over prime fields or
one advantage of that
is that you might work over prime fields
and then
another
natural direction of course we just
talked about read solomon codes mostly
but
there are lots of other codes and it
would be really neat if you could
compute linear functions
uh on data encoded in other codes as
well
so these are some directions for future
work we just kind of defined this
problem of encoding on computing on
encoded data
and there are a lot of similar ideas out
there and hopefully this is just the
beginning of
lots more work to come
so uh here are my references
thank you
very much for watching my talk
and i hope to see you at itcs
thanks